Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of getting
an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Behold the biggest spectacle
in history.
[ scoffs ]
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
This isn't about a product.
This is about an empire.
You're dead.
You're gonna get
knocked off like that.
Narrator: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
which one of you sharks
will marry Paparazzi Proposals?
Narrator: ...they're ready
to invest using their own money.
Get off your knees.
Let's talk about money.
And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You're being
a hypocrite, Lori.
Lori, you're being
a hypocrite.
No, I'm not
being a hypocrite.
Yes.
You're interrupting me.
So you haven't even heard
what I'm saying yet.
I heard
what you said earlier.
No one's even talked
about the fact
that he's asking
over a million-dollar valuation.
Enough!
Take it or leave it.
Narrator:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went from
waiting tables in manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of qvc,
holds over 100 patents,
and has launched
over 300 products
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban, notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is an entrepreneur
with a new way to serve
an old-fashioned dessert.
Are you guys ready
for something good?
for something new?
[ laughs ]
My name is Sarah Schulz,
and I am the founder, the baker,
and the mastermind
of Schulzies bread pudding.
I'm seeking investment
of $160,000
for a 20% equity stake
in Schulzies.
Schulzies is rich, creamy,
delicious, fresh bread pudding.
I'll let your taste buds
go for it,
and you can see
the proof is in the pudding.
All right.
Sweet Home Strawberry.
Thank you, Sarah.
And you have
my Celestial Chocolate Chunk...
GREINER: That is just what
I wanted, looking at the sign.
...with a caramel sauce.
And for you, Mr. Wonderful,
Coconut with a little bit
of strawberry sauce.
O'Leary: Thank you,
thank you.
Wow.
This is
the Caramel Charisma.
Mm, thank you.
Mark,
Radical Raspberry.
There you go.
Greiner:
This is amazing.
O'Leary: Sarah, it's amazing.
Mm. Delicious.
Cuban: Incredible.
Oh, my God.
How many calories
in this?
No calories, Kevin.
[ laughs ] 9,000.
Wow.
This isn't bread pudding.
There is a child here,
so you won't look like this if
you keep eating bread pudding.
[ laughter ]
Who's ready to build
a bread-pudding empire with me?
So, tell us
what the business is?
There's nothing like it
on the market.
People don't know what it is,
so I need it to say,
"here I am, world.
I got bread pudding."
You rented
retail space?
Not any old retail.
I got on my bike
in Venice Beach,
and I found
a little tiny window
right across from Muscle Beach,
where they work out,
that I rented
for about a year and a half.
And I recently did
a asset purchase agreement
a little over a year ago
and let someone else run it
so I could really do
my vision.
You ran away
from your business.
No, not even close!
Are you ready?
Ready.
I got my dream --
A bread-pudding parlor,
and it's in San Francisco,
and it is beautiful.
[ laughs ]
But Sarah,
is that a store?
Greiner:
Is this like a store?
So, it's a store.
O'Leary: Okay, okay.
And so, we have
the walk-up window.
Sarah, remember the little
window across from Muscle Beach?
Yes.
How many square feet
was that?
It was 140 square feet.
140 square feet?
Yeah, it's just
this little tiny window --
How many dollars
in sales last year in that?
Last year,
it was $190,000.
Sarah, how did you go from
Venice Beach to San Francisco?
So, San Francisco,
it's part-Time home,
and also, though, they have
a really unique foodie market.
Is your
San Francisco store
different from your
Venice Beach store?
It's a walk-Through,
brick-and-mortar location.
It has more flavors. You --
How many square feet?
San Francisco
is 800 square feet.
This is a mock-up,
so you could kind of
generally see
what is
a bread-pudding parlor.
So, you're a yogurt store
with bread pudding?
[ laughter ]
O'Leary: Sarah.
So, Sarah, stay focused
on the numbers for a second.
Yes.
How much are you gonna rent
that 800 square feet for?
It's $3,200 a month.
You mean, San Francisco
is open now?
Yes.
What did it do in sales
last month?
So, last month,
we did $30,000.
That's --
That's okay.
That sounds
pretty good to me.
It does to me, too.
It's good,
but I'm not satisfied.
I want more.
I'm this entrepreneur
that has ideas,
and I'm a mover
and a shaker.
Okay, so here's
a problem right now, all right?
The way to look at it
is dollars per square
foot of sales.
Correct.
That's how you can become
a franchisable business.
Your first concept
was to open up 140 square feet,
and you were actually
selling $1,300 a foot,
which is
very, very good.
It was.
Okay?
Then you moved
to San Francisco.
Based on
the first 3 months,
you've dropped
from $1,300
down to $450
per square foot of sales,
which is not good.
You're not gonna make
any money this year
if that store
stays at that level,
'cause you got to pay people,
and you have to pay the rent.
And you've got $200,000
of capex to amortize.
What happened between
Muscle Beach and San Francisco?
It's a whole new Market.
Muscle Beach
has the foot traffic.
Then I moved
to San Francisco.
People haven't heard
about me.
I have spent no money
in marketing whatsoever.
Cuban: Let me
ask you a question.
How much money
have you invested?
I have put in $300,000.
Whoa.
I'm curious.
Where did you get that money?
It was from my dad, and that's
why it's his name -- Schulzies.
And as he passed, it was a gift,
and I invested it all.
That was the total amount
he left you?
Yes.
Okay, Sarah, what's missing
in your presentation
is sort of the
operational-execution aspect.
It's not investable,
not for me.
I don't know that you're
gonna execute a business plan
because there isn't
a business plan yet.
Just my opinion.
I'm out.
Okay.
For me, I don't doubt
at all
that you don't love
your bread pudding.
Mm-hmm.
And absolutely delicious.
Right.
Cuban: Amazing.
But I couldn't imagine making
money with you, for some reason.
I'm gonna have to trust
my instinct on that. I'm out.
And there is not a question
in my mind
that this isn't
just about a business.
This isn't about a product.
This is about an empire.
Your passion for the product
is fantastic.
I don't think you did
a -- a great job
in showing me a business plan
that I can get excited about.
It's there.
It's not.
The direction's there.
Sarah,
it's not there today.
All right.
I'm out.
Look, the problem is you,
by yourself.
You need a complementary partner
who can guide you.
You need that desperately,
desperately.
You have a great idea.
You have a great opportunity.
Your biggest risk is you.
For that reason,
I'm out.
All right.
Greiner:
I love the saying,
"Don't go
where the path may lead.
Go where there is no path,
and leave a Trail."
You could be on the brink
of something fantastic,
but I wish
you were more there.
I-I see you
as teetering right now.
For me, it's not the right time
to invest in your company.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Great product.
Greiner:
Yeah, great product.
Thanks, Sarah.
Herjavec:
Thank you, Sarah.
Watch out
for bread-pudding parlors.
Corcoran: Okay.
Everywhere.
I want to get up
and go try more.
To hear them tell me
How great
Schulzies bread pudding is,
it was confirmation.
I will never stop Schulzies
until it needs to get
to where it needs to be.
Radical Raspberry.
Greiner:
Look at us pigs.
Oh, don't double-dip.
[ laughs ]
What do you mean?
My name's James Ambler.
I live in New York City
with my wife, Kate,
and my 1-year-old daughter,
Milla,
and I am the proud owner
of Paparazzi Proposals.
I've been
a paparazzi photographer
for the last six years
in New York City.
Being a paparazzi photographer
has really helped me
in building this business.
I don't get flustered
under pressure,
and no matter what happens,
we're always gonna get
that shot.
I'm amazed that no one's really
come up with this idea before.
Since we've started it,
there's a lot of companies
that are trying to copy
what we do,
but no one can capture the
moment like Paparazzi Proposals.
Tickle, tickle,
tickle, tickle. Yeah.
I've risked a lot
to make this dream come True.
I gave up a very stable, steady
job. I have a young family.
We have another child
on the way,
and so I have a lot riding
on the success of this business.
We're really hoping
to get a deal with the sharks.
I hope that the romance
of it all
will manage to sweep
a few of them off their feet.
Hello,
my name's James Ambler,
and I'm the proud owner
of Paparazzi Proposals.
We are asking for $250,000
for 20% equity in our company.
I've been
a paparazzi photographer
for the last six years,
and now I use
these sneaky skills
to help capture
that amazing question
that every girl wants to hear.
Paparazzi Proposals came about
four years ago
when I proposed to my wife,
and after we started to tell
friends and family
about our engagement,
the first question
that everybody asked was,
"How did he do it?"
this got me thinking.
It would have been so cool
to have some pictures
of me down on one knee.
So, I started looking into it
and researching to see
if there was anybody
or any company out there
offering this unique service,
and there wasn't.
So, in June 2011,
we launched Paparazzi Proposals.
And I've spent
the last two years
marketing and branding
this unique company in America.
So, sharks, it just leaves me
with just one very big question
that I need to ask you.
I'm rather nervous about it.
[ laughter ]
Which one of you sharks
will marry Paparazzi Proposals?
[ laughter ]
Get off your knees.
Let's talk about money.
Okay, why do you need
a quarter of a million dollars?
We've really been focusing
this business
in New York City
where I'm based,
and we want
to use that money
to help expand
into other cities.
The other angle
that we've done
is we go into jewelry stores,
and we educate the jewelers
about our service.
The key success to this
is getting jewelers excited
and on board
and wanting to put this
into their clients' hand
as they give them
their engagement ring.
What's in it for them?
We offered a kickback
for the jewelers to start with.
With the social marketing
and the media that's out there,
this is a great product
for a jeweler to advertise
their -- their product.
Okay.
What were your sales?
We did just under $100,000
in sales in the last two years.
Why are you so focused
on the jewelers?
'Cause I think
it's key to the success.
Why not wedding shows?
Why not wedding magazines?
Oh, yeah, 'cause lots of guys
watch those.
"Oh, wait, the game's up,
but I'm gonna get proposed."
Well, no,
but hang on, Mark.
"Let's turn on
the Wedding Channel."
Well, you know, I see
this as, like, a cross
between a private eye...
Yeah.
...and a wedding
photographer...
Yeah, good analogy.
...because it has to look
really good, quality.
Exactly.
But they
have to hide out.
The main idea is, guys need help
planning their proposals,
so we find out his ideas,
where -- w-where and how
he might be looking to propose.
We offer him help
with any kind of logistics,
if he wants flowers there.
So you give them
suggestions.
Yeah.
You aid with flowers
or something romantic,
and then you also are there
to capture the moment.
Exactly.
Part of the reason
that we're looking
for investment
is also to partner
with someone
who may be able
to put us into Kay's and Jared.
That'd be a huge, huge, huge,
enormous mistake,
because if you did,
and they put it in 20 stores,
you're dead, right?
Really?
Because how are you
going to keep up?
Let's just say they brought you
five deals a week,
and you're in charge
with managing, quality,
and making sure they're all
fulfilled properly...
right.
...and following up
and making sure that
everything works, right?
Exactly.
A business
can die from success.
Well, but he also
could handle it.
Oh, there's no way,
there's no way.
Wait, wait.
In a service-oriented,
creative business,
if you make a deal
with a big retailer
who's gonna put you
in 20 stores,
you don't have time
to figure that out.
But wait a minute,
time out. Time out.
And that's a great way
to lose customers.
O'Leary: I don't know
why you guys are fighting.
No one's even talked
about the fact
that he's asking
over a million-dollar
valuation of this idea.
Whoa, Kevin. Why is it worth
that much money? $1.2 million.
It isn't. It isn't. It isn't.
There's so much competition.
Greiner: Wait.
Herjavec:
James, speak to that.
Why is your business
worth $1. --
time out, whoa, whoa.
I want to go back to what Mark
was saying.
Can I -- can I -- I'll be
with you very shortly.
Can I just answer
Lori's question first?
Greiner: back to what -- back to
what mark was saying, though --
We will talk about
your valuation...
I know, Kevin.
...which, by the way,
is insane.
I know, thank you.
No, it is.
We've got to deal with it.
It's so insane,
I have to hear now why.
Yeah, well, I'd just like
to address Lori,
who actually
was trying to --
then you're avoiding
the real question.
Thank you very much.
No, no,
I will come back to you.
I do want to go back to that,
to Kevin's point.
That's
very kind of you.
But the thing is,
I see this as something
that you could fully manage.
He could have maybe
40 different things written up
as ways
in which to propose.
It's a template. He could have
his staff use it.
He could operate
out of New York, Mark.
That's exactly the model
that we're going to use.
He could operate
out of his home.
You don't even need
a lot of office space.
But what's your point?
My point is is that he
could easily scale this
fast and quick.
You'd get crushed.
Now, look. I love
two industries very much.
I love weddings,
and I love people dying.
You know why?
Because when both
of those happen,
people make stupid decisions,
emotional decisions,
not financial decisions.
And because
that is the case,
there's huge industries
behind both of those,
including a whole ton of
wedding photographers out there
that could
easily do this.
And I don't really see you
being significantly different.
You are not worth
$1.25 million, my friend.
Okay.
I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Look, James, you should
be growing organically,
taking your wins
from one city to the next,
because if it truly
can scale,
and it truly can grow,
like Lori seems to think...
Yep.
...then you could make
a boatload of money in New York,
then move to Chicago,
boatload in Chicago,
then move to L.A.,
rather than trying to hit
all these cities at one time.
Right.
And so, because
I don't think
this is
an investment conducive
to my getting a return,
I'm out.
Okay, thank you
very much for your time.
You're welcome
very much.
Well, James, I think
you're a fantastic operator.
Thank you.
I just can't get over
the $250,000.
I figure
it has a potential to earn
uh, a lot more
than half a million.
James, I think you're nuts
going out of New York
until you've saturated
that market,
and this is not a business
for an investor.
This is your business,
your concierge service.
I can't imagine
making money on this business
as an outsider
coming in.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you,
again, Barbara.
You're welcome,
my friend.
You know, I think the idea
is amazing.
Thank you.
I think
it's a home run.
The romantic in me,
and I think, Barb, you -- You --
Romantic, too --
I'm not a romantic,
definitely not.
Well,
the romantic in me --
I think this is fantastic.
To have a memory
of your proposal is great.
The problem that I have
is your valuation.
I don't see where you need
the $250,000.
That's my problem...
okay.
...because I don't think
that you need to put
a lot of money
into this business at all.
How's he going to train
all the jewelers that you
thought was a great idea?
I still think
it's a great idea.
How is he gonna
train them
and send people
to introduce it?
And I think you should go
to tuxedo places.
I'll tell you
the difference.
When I started, I,
just myself, figured it out.
And you know what, Mark?
I pounded the pavement.
I went, 21 cities, 18 days.
You're -- You're
missing the point.
You're being a hypocrite, Lori.
Lori, you're being a hypocrite.
No, I'm not
being a hypocrite.
Yes, you're saying he's got
the right idea to scale --
but you're being rude
because you're interrupting me.
You're saying he's got
the right idea to scale,
but then you're telling him
he doesn't need the money.
Wait.
But you've got to go out
and train everybody.
Wait, wait.
No, you're saying that.
That's not
what I'm saying.
You said it.
You're interrupting me.
So you haven't even heard
what I'm saying yet.
I heard
what you said earlier...
No, you need to stop.
...that it was a great,
scalable idea.
Time out, Mark.
So, he doesn't have to go
to these other cities --
But --
Okay, so let's just say
within New York,
all the different
jewelry companies.
But you know what?
You -- but you said
it was a great idea
to go
to the different jewelers.
He finds who is --
Who -- Who's the top buyer
for Kay jewelers.
He finds
who's the top buyer.
What's a buyer gonna do?
It's the people who sell it
that are gonna do the work.
What I'm saying is, he goes in,
he sells it to them.
They get
their staff enlisted.
The staff then --
are you kidding me?
No, I'm not kidding you.
I did it myself.
So the buyer -- the buyer
of a jewelry company...
mark.
...is gonna go to the people
who run the retail floor...
I went --
...and tell them
to train the retail sales people
to sell the service.
Yes, absolutely.
If it's an initiative
that that store wants to do,
and they make a kickback,
absolutely.
I've seen it done
all the time.
O'Leary: Why are you
fighting about this
when the whole business
isn't worth $250,000?
Look. Wait.
I just wish you'd come in here
with a different offer.
You simply say to him,
"I'll give you $250,000
for 250% of this company."
[ laughs ]
That's the only way
you can do this deal.
For me
to give you $250,000,
I would want
a lot bigger piece of the pie.
Narrator: Three sharks are out.
Lori seems interested,
but the 20% stake
James is offering is too small.
For me
to give you $250,000,
I would want
a lot bigger piece of the pie
because I feel like
I could show you
how to take this business and
quickly get it off the ground
without needing
a big staff.
So, I will
make you an offer.
Okay.
I'm offering you
$250,000,
but I'm gonna want 50%
because I see us winding up
being equal partners.
James, your business isn't even
worth half a million right now,
and yet you've
just got that offer.
Are you
out of your mind?
It doesn't make sense that you
wouldn't take that offer.
Ambler: I'm very humbled
'cause this has been
my heart and soul for two years.
This has to work.
But part of the reason
this has to work
is because I have to believe
and trust in myself.
I have to hold my head high,
and I have to respect myself.
50% equity, it's just
not gonna work for me.
So, if there's
a negotiation
that we can maybe start
to do a little dance --
Well, the negotiating works
with you making a counteroffer.
I think there's a different way
to structure it, Lori.
Oh, no question you think
there's a different way
to structure it.
And so let me explain
what would be more interesting
for your money,
because I'm very married --
married --
Ohh!
I'm very married to mine,
and we're very happy together.
You know how you know
it's a bad deal?
No, it's gonna be
a great deal.
Kevin's talking.
Do you want to
hear it, or not?
Sure, why not?
Greiner:
I want to hear it.
Okay.
I'll go in with Lori.
And I'll slightly change
the structure, all right?
[ laughs ]
We will give you $50,000
for a third of the business,
all right?
That's the equity piece.
And we'll loan you
$200,000 as you need it.
That way, we can actually
make a deal that makes sense
because your deal doesn't.
Well, you know,
I rarely agree with Kevin.
Ambler: Okay.
But I think that was
a good, creative, new offer.
O'Leary: Thank you. Are you
interested in partnering?
I am interested
in partnering with him.
So, he's valuing
you company
at less than the cash
you were asking for coming in.
Yeah, I was -- I know.
Correct, my friend.
Let me call your wife.
[ laughter ]
Um, can I just talk
before you contact my wife?
You may.
Yeah, thank you.
Um, Robert,
you were on the fence.
I'll give you $100,000
under the same terms.
It's a very clever way
to structure the deal.
Thank you.
So, I'll give you
$100,000
for one-third
of the business today
and loan you the rest
as you need it
to expand
the business.
So, I've got
a counteroffer for you.
Lori, partner with Robert,
and we'll do a deal.
'cause Lori brings so much
to this table.
Do you
not want my offer?
I don't not want it.
I would just like to see
what Lori thinks about that.
Do the deal with Lori. Robert,
let her do the deal with Lori.
So, my offer isn't good enough
unless I bring Lori in.
No, no, no, not at all.
But I'm
a stopgap for you.
Yeah, you're the girl
that didn't get the
proposal, but don't worry.
Stay -- stick around
in case the first one says no.
I'm -- I'm not good
at playing second fiddle.
I thought I made you
a very fair offer
when these guys didn't give you
the value you deserve today.
Take it or leave it.
Thank you.
I will give you an answer
very shortly.
Ohh!
James, I'll give you
an answer right now.
I'm out.
So, all roads be,
as they are,
leading back to Mr. Wonderful,
yet again.
So now you're back
to the original offer, $50,000.
Your offer's
ridiculous.
An additional $200,000
as a loan as you need it.
Yeah,
that's horrible.
Then why don't you
make an offer?
Instead of
insulting my offer.
I don't want him
to make a stupid mistake!
CORCORAN: Let him answer.
Greiner: Why are you saying
he's making a mistake?
Because I think he's
making a horrid mistake
if he does 50k for --
he has two
very smart sharks here.
That's fine.
O'Leary: Then make him
a better offer.
Enough!
Calm down.
What do you want to do?
I want to add
one thing.
I started grassroots --
One product, one idea --
and I had to tackle
everything to get out
there in the market...
we already heard that story,
Lori. What are you gonna do?
...to build
a $500-Million brand.
We've heard this story already,
Lori. What are we gonna do?
So he's going to benefit greatly
from what's right here.
What I know
that you can do --
James, you lost -- You lost
one offer because you -- You
weren't clear and concise.
This is like
a marriage proposal.
Would the deal go down to 30%,
we have a deal.
Because I know it's 33.3%,
but I came in here 30%.
We're good
with that.
We're good with that.
Done.
Who wants the ring?
[ laughs ]
we get the ring.
Herjavec: Wow.
What?
O'Leary: I'll give it
to my sharkette partner.
I don't get that.
Thank you for marrying
Paparazzi Proposals.
Ah! Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
I think
I'm going to cry.
Thank you.
Thank you very much
for taking the time.
Thank you. Good luck.
I really appreciate it.
Corcoran: Good luck.
Thank you.
Ambler: I'm really surprised
I made a deal with Kevin,
'cause I was really going
after Lori and maybe Robert,
but Robert got his knickers
in a twist
and decided
to go home early.
Greiner:
I'm making a proclamation.
A year from now,
this is gonna be huge.
And you know, Lori,
he saved your Butt.
Him restructuring
the deal --
You were about to go down that
path and make a stupid deal.
No.
Thank god he jumped in,
definitely.
I never make deals
that I think are stupid.
I hate to admit it,
but he did.
He got you
the right deal on that.
I do what I believe in.
Barbara, kiss the ring.
Narrator: Last season,
Rabbi Moshe Weiss made a deal
with Daymond for his ipad
accessory, the soundbender.
It clips right onto the back
magnetically, beautifully,
reflecting the sound
right towards you.
Narrator: Let's see
what he's doing now.
Weiss: Who would have thought
that, in only one year,
a Rabbi
from St. Paul, minnesota,
would be flying down
to New York City
for a sales meeting
with Daymond John?
Daymond!
[ Laughs ]
Moshe, welcome
to new York, man.
It's good
to see you, Buddy.
How you doing?
I'm great, man.
Before "Shark Tank,"
Sales were at $7,000.
Post "Shark Tank,"
we're nearing $250,000.
So one of the reasons
I brought you out here today
was to talk about licensing
and introduce you
to Scott
at The Wish Factory.
Licensing is an amazing
opportunity for soundbender.
You get a large company
to basically
do all the work for you,
manufacture it,
bill it, ship it,
and every quarter,
you get a check.
So, Moshe, I wanted to introduce
you to The Wish Factory team.
So, in anticipation
of your coming here today,
we've done a little bit
of ground work.
We're going to take
Marvel's "Avengers"
And marry that
to soundbender.
Wish Factory's
gonna guarantee to sell
$2 million
worth of soundbenders a year.
That's the minimum guarantee.
You are my superheroes.
We're thrilled
that you're thrilled.
Weiss: Having a partner
and mentor like Daymond John
is a dream come True
because he's all about you
and building the brand
within you.
All right.
Awesome, man! Whoo!
Done deal.
[ laughs ]
Narrator:
Next up is an innovative way
to communicate with babies
before they're even born.
Hello.
My name is Curtis.
And I'm Matt.
And we're the founders
of Bellybuds.
Today, we're seeking
an investment of $500,000
in exchange for 12 1/2%
of our company.
[ scoffs ]
and this is our lovely friend,
Danielle,
who happens to be
6 months pregnant.
Now, we've all heard
that playing music
to a baby in the womb
can be beneficial,
but there's never been
a product
designed specifically
for that task, until now.
Bellybuds.
[ laughter ]
Bellybuds is
a baby Bump sound-System
that gently
and discreetly adheres
to a pregnant woman's belly
and allows her to play music
and voices to the baby
in the womb anytime,
anywhere.
Thank you, Danielle.
Wow.
So, when my wife was pregnant
with our oldest daughter,
she used what she had, which was
her regular, tiny earbuds,
and pressed them
to her stomach.
But those are made
for your ears, not your belly.
So, that's where the idea
of Bellybuds was conceived.
Curt came up, approached me,
and asked
if I would like to be
a partner with him on this.
I, of course, thought two guys
selling a pregnancy product --
How could I resist?
[ laughter ]
But then I read the studies
that are out there,
and not only do babies
hear inside the womb,
but they actually learn
and form memories, as well.
For example, if you play
certain songs with Bellybuds
while you're pregnant,
you can play those same songs
after the baby is born
to help soothe them.
So it suction-cups
to her stomach.
Is it like
a traditional earbud, or --
WILLIAMS: It's -- Yeah, it's
actually not a suction cup.
It's a medical-grade,
hydro-gel adhesive.
Each pair lasts
for about 20 uses,
and then each package comes
with replacement adhesives,
and then we also sell
those as a separate sku.
Matt, can I see
one of your packages there?
O'Leary: You g-- You guys
must have a lot of sales
for this valuation.
It's a $4 million company.
Williams: Yes.
Von waaden: Yes.
Our sales in 2012
were about $300,000.
To date, the first half
of this year,
we're at about $340,000.
We are approaching
a $1.1 million
gross product sales.
And what's your profit
on that?
We're, uh, running
a negative.
Bad answer.
Well, we're -- We're
a growing company.
And, you know, every dollar
that we make,
we're reinvesting
into our company.
How much did you lose
in the first year
and the second year, so far?
First year,
we lost $175,000.
[ whistles ]
2012,
we lost $140,000.
Why are you
losing money?
Well, we learned a very valuable
lesson last year.
I think you're about
to learn another one.
Yeah, well, we made a couple
of unfortunate sales
at the beginning
of last year.
We were --
What is
an unfortunate sale?
Williams:
It's selling to buyers
who said they were going
to distribute the product
in a certain place,
and it ended up being online,
undercut the price,
and it undercut
our sales ourselves,
and then
all our retailers.
Oh, so your retailers
freaked out.
Yeah.
What did they do?
Because that means that you had
some upset retailers.
Yeah, well, they
were wondering about our
control of the product,
so we made the decision
to stop selling
in order to let all those units
flush out of the market,
'cause we wanted it to
be over quickly rather
than draw it out.
The lesson we learned,
obviously,
was we need
to know our customers better.
So we contacted
our existing customers,
told them our plan.
They were happy with us.
They stayed with us.
And since
that has happened,
we've seen our sales
again go back up.
That's fair enough.
Good for you.
Good recovery.
Greiner: So, a good question is,
what do they sell for?
The retail price
is $49.99.
And what's your cost to make
an individual package?
Less than $10.
Do you have
a patent on it?
We are patent pending
right now,
as well as we have
several registered trademarks,
and we own our --
Well, the trademarks
won't save you
as far as
somebody else making this.
Fair enough,
fair enough.
What about competition?
There are similar products
on the market.
We are, far and away,
the coolest.
All three of my kids, you know,
going on ten years ago,
we would do this,
not that that's a --
Herjavec: Did you use
a different product?
Yeah, we used
a different product.
There -- There are other things
out on the market.
You know, most of them are belts
or straps or wraparound.
If mark has already
bought something
that was not the exact same,
but similar function...
Functionally,
functionally.
...then why would you think
you'd get a patent?
Williams: Well, it's never been
done with adhesive before,
and what that allows is that
you can move them anywhere.
A lot of times, mom will know
where the baby is.
'cause every
other thing is --
So, how long
has it been pending?
Uh, three years.
Three years.
Conservative approach.
So you probably
aren't going to get a patent.
Let's assume it
conservatively that you're
not gonna get a patent.
Okay.
You have a brand
some people know.
You've been selling some.
You're hoping to sell
a million this year.
You come in here
asking for $500,000.
I don't know
what this company's worth today.
It's never made any money.
In my book, that kind of matters
a little bit.
How did you get
to the $4 million?
The first thing
that we have is,
you know, roughly
$110,000 in cash.
Okay, so I deduct that
from the $4 million.
I'm still
asking myself, "Whoa."
I understand that.
"How is this company
worth $3.9 million?"
we have $1.3 million
sitting in our warehouse today
ready to be sold.
Inventory.
So you made inventory
before sales?
Yes.
We have high hopes
for the growth.
Today --
We're at the --
GREINER: See, that's back
to what I was saying.
We're at the beg--
When I hear,
"We have high hopes,
but we invested in all of this
inventory up front"...
no, no, no, but we --
...it doesn't sound
good to me,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
Thanks, Lori.
Thank you, Lori.
I think your price
of $500,000 for any percentage
is outrageous
based on the sales.
I'm out
truly for the numbers.
I think your whole company's
worth 500k right now,
the whole thing.
I'm very simple to understand.
I like to make money.
There's no way
to make money with you guys.
I'm out.
I love the packaging.
I love the design.
I love the story
until mark said,
"Yeah, I've been using this
for the last nine years
with each
of my children."
I don't think
you did enough
to differentiate
between your product
and all the other products
that are out there.
We've been
the number-One brand online
for about two years now.
And So,
as a number-One brand,
it's equal to trailing revenue
of $400,000.
It's a gro--
It's an expanding market.
I don't want to waste
your time. I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you for your time.
Okay, guys. I'm just gonna be
brutally honest.
Williams: Okay.
Any type of
consumer-electronics product,
and particularly
when you make it in China,
you're gonna get
knocked off like that.
Particularly,
you don't have a patent.
They're gonna say,
"These guys are selling them
for $35 or $25 at wholesale.
We'll sell them
for $10."
I think you've got
a business here,
but I think you're
gonna get knocked off
all the way
to Hong Kong.
I'm out.
The good news is,
when that child's born,
it's going to be
an accountant.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you
for your time.
Thanks a lot, guys.
I think what happened
in there was
they really liked
the product,
and we just had a problem
with the valuation.
But we know what's happening.
We know the industry.
We know
where this is going.
So, it's disappointing,
you know.
We wish they had shared
our vision.
Narrator: Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
from Camarillo, California,
with an innovative
new cosmetic line.
Hi, my name's Abe Geary,
and I'm seeking $200,000
for a 20% equity stake
in my company.
Behold what could be the biggest
spectacle in history.
What I'm about to show you
is incredible.
Introducing...
Petpaint.
"Colored hair spray
for your dog"?
Release the hounds!
Busting through
your local tailgate party
is London the Bulldog.
[ laughter ]
[ scoffs ]
win, lose, or draw,
you know
who he's barking for.
I like the colors.
Check out Billie.
She's rocking
stars and flowers.
And like every fashionista,
she knows life is a catwalk.
Aww!
Petpaint is
a veterinarian-Tested,
super bright, washable,
easy-to-use color spray.
And with our full line
of stencils, anyone can do it.
Even you, Mr. Wonderful.
I would love
for you sharks
to come swim
in this dog-eat-dog world.
Did you just
wake up one morning saying,
"I want to spray-paint dogs?"
HERJAVEC:
[ laughs ]
A-Actually,
these two are mine.
This is Billie,
and this is monkey.
And, um, I tried to get
a-a-a shirt to stay on my dog,
and she tore it off
immediately.
I was like, "There's got to be
something out there
that -- That they don't know
they're wearing."
So a couple years of research,
and we have Petpaint now.
Cuban: So, you say you spent
a couple years working on this.
How much money
have you invested?
I've got about $240,000
invested into this.
Is that your --
your own money?
Yes.
Corcoran:
That's a lot of money.
What did you spend it on?
Well, it is,
but the majority of it
I still have
in inventory, so --
H-How much of that
is inventory?
I've got about $200,000
in inventory.
Wow.
Greiner: So, I have a question
for you I think is important.
I'm not really sure
that something like this
is patentable.
Geary: We have some patents
pending on some key ingredients,
but you can't own
color on dogs.
What happens if you
take Winston Churchill over
there, and you spray him red,
and he runs around the house
against the drapes?
As long as you -- You let it
dry, you're good.
Okay, so how long
does it take to dry?
It's about
20 to 30 seconds.
Okay, that's not bad.
What happens
if a dog licks this paint?
Greiner: Yeah.
Any damage?
We've tested it
for toxicity,
and we've tested it
for skin irritants,
and -- And both has -- has
passed with flying colors.
I don't know how often people
are gonna wake up and say,
"I want to spray-paint
my dog blue,"
other than a holiday
or a festive party.
How many times a year
are you gonna turn
a little rat dog like that
into a zebra?
Corcoran: It's fun.
Why not?
Herjavec:
The zebra is cool.
Do you have --
do you have dogs?
No, I have children.
I don't need dogs.
Okay, it -- it may be
a bit foreign,
but if you're super dad
and you bring your family dog
home with stars
to your 8-year-old
daughter's birthday,
you're gonna be the hero.
Yeah, it's very cool.
Cuban:
You're gonna be the hero.
Corcoran: Abe, you're asking
a hefty amount of money --
$200,000
for 20% of your business.
Why don't you tell us
How great your sales are?
I bet they're amazing.
Since it landed
in my warehouse in March,
we've sold $70,000
worth of paint.
And it sells
for how much?
It's $9.99.
Okay.
Now, here's
the interesting part of that.
So, we've got
a 50-store deal with Petsmart.
They want to retail it, but they
also want it in their salon.
Is this a potential deal?
Is this an actual deal?
Do you have any --
We're shipping
in about two weeks.
And how much
are you shipping?
Yeah, we have
about 12,000 moving.
12,000 units,
you said?
12,000 --
I think I totaled it up.
It's about
$12,000 worth.
Oh, $12,000 worth.
Initial order,
50-Store test.
Do you have the purchase order
for the 50-Store test?
It's in my inbox.
What do you project
the sales will be
in the next 12 months?
By close of business
this year,
I'm looking to do
another $120,000 in sales.
So, we should be
right around $200,000.
Based on what?
My distributors
and to the groomers --
Grooming industry have reordered
five times already.
I think it's a great idea
for groomers.
I think it's
very, very unique.
You know what
I think the product lacks?
A good price.
It's $10 for one can?
I don't think
that's an easy buy.
So, I have to see this
as a one-time play
for halloween, maybe
for a birthday here or there.
And I don't really see it
selling well
at that price point, so I'm out.
I'm sorry
to hear that.
So, Abe, I'm gonna tell you
a story, okay?
4,000 years ago, there was
a people called the phoenicians.
They found a way
to take sea mollusks,
crush their shells,
and make purple dye.
Because it was
such a rare color,
everybody wanted purple robes
for royalty.
These guys would dye the sails
of their boats purple
and sail into every war zone
in the Mediterranean.
Nobody touched them.
You know why?
Everybody wanted
the purple robes.
Everybody else got killed,
but never the phoenicians.
No one else knew how
to crush the snails
to make the purple Dye.
Did you
just make that up?
No.
Of course
he made that up.
That is a true story.
[ laughs ]
I never heard that before.
And so --
What's your point
with that?
This -- My point is this.
If you had the purple dye
no one else could make,
you could sail off
and make millions of dollars,
but you don't.
Everybody can make
a colored spray for a dog.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
You're not a phoenician, Abe.
Sorry.
What's -- What
are you doing online?
We're not doing much online.
Why not?
I just spent my attention
with the larger people,
with the industry leaders,
with --
But didn't it cross
your mind
that retail could be
the worst possible side
of the business
for you?
I just -- I just
have not focused
all my attention
onto that.
My first concern
is when you said
that you had bought up $200,000
worth of inventory.
You should never invest
in inventory
until you have sales,
because you don't know
how long you're going to sit
with that inventory.
The other thing is,
they might do it once,
but then they might
grow old of it, you know,
and maybe only do it
a few times a year.
So, I hope you do
get those sales,
but for me, I am out.
Cuban: I agree with Lori
in some respects.
You took a big risk,
but that also shows
your commitment.
But where I have
a huge, huge problem
is that you weren't able
to see that online
was your best solution.
You use social media,
and they post pictures
of all the pets
that they painted,
and it's self-fulfilling,
and you don't have
all that risk.
But you didn't see that.
It's not that you can't do it.
It's that you didn't see it.
To me,
that's so obvious,
and then to me,
that's a huge red flag.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
The biggest challenge, and
the greatest asset that we have
is that it's a new and exciting
product, okay,
so that I can spend --
all the more reason
why the web
would have worked
great for you.
It -- it would have,
but people see it
and go, "I don't know."
are you kidding me?
All they got to do
is take a picture.
Every kid
with Instagram
that's -- That's
posting pictures of their dogs,
and, you know,
"Where'd you get it?
Where'd you get it?"
it's so easy
and so obvious.
That scares me
that you couldn't see that.
There's only
one shark left.
It's Robert.
Robert,
what are you gonna do?
God, you know, I-I --
usually, I'm so decisive.
Uh...
Narrator: Four sharks are out,
and Robert is Abe's
last chance to get a deal.
God, you know, I-I --
usually, I'm so decisive.
Mark brings up
a great point
'cause my kids
use social media all the time,
and they see
cute things like this,
they're gonna
search it out.
They would have
found you.
I mean,
I-I love the idea.
But are you the guy
to take that great idea
with your current strategy
and get it out to the market?
I don't think you'll find
anybody better.
O'Leary: Are you saying --
are you saying Abe
is not a Phoenician?
I -- You know,
I haven't even talked
about the million-dollar value
you put on the business today.
I'm just not
seeing it today.
What would it take?
Hey, Abe, I'm gonna
give you an offer.
Barbara,
I thought you were out.
I changed my mind.
$200,000, which you
came in for,
but I would have to take
60% of your business.
[ laughs ]
Wait, don't laugh at it.
Hold on.
But I'd be doing you
a great favor,
because I would take over
your social media space.
I would have you
up with a fabulous website,
and you want
to know something?
You'd make
a ton of money.
But you are so stubborn
that you'd have
to really move out of my way
and let me take over
the sales of this...
I --
...because you're
hooked to --
Mark's very most
valid point --
The most obvious play here
is the website,
and that's
where your gold is.
I-I don't disagree
with Mark.
Um, that --
I agree with you 100%.
Barb, what's your offer
going to be?
Now -- but that's
an offer, okay?
So, the -- What is your offer?
$200,000 for 60% --
$200,000 for 60%
of the business,
but think about this.
You don't have to do
any work.
You just sit
on the sidelines
and enjoy
counting your cash.
60%, like --
I don't want to tell you
no right off the bat,
but I need the value.
You know what the other value
is? Good judgment.
Yeah.
Okay?
You don't have
the judgment,
I think, to make
the right plays.
You need a little help
in that area.
And that's a big part.
Can we -- can We --
can we step back
a little bit?
Herjavec: Abe, I'm gonna let you
focus on Barbara.
I'm trying to get there.
I just can't get there.
But let me --
Let me --
I'm out.
O'Leary: Okay, now there's
one shark still in.
She offered you
$200,000 for 60%.
I don't think your whole
company's worth $200,000,
to be Frank with you,
for reasons
I've already discussed.
But there's an offer.
What are you gonna do?
Are you gonna take her offer
or Not?
Look, I don't want
to partner with somebody
who's just looking
to grab equity,
'cause this is gonna be
incredibly successful.
I take that as a no.
I'm gonna have to say no.
I'll see you guys
on the internet.
Good luck.
Thank you.
[ whistles, smooches ]
Oh, my.
[ laughter ]
Well, the dogs
listen to him.
The dogs
are his best asset.
I couldn't take the deal
with Barbara.
She wanted too much equity,
but I am going to take
her advice
and all the rest
of the sharks',
and you will see
Petpaint online.